so we recently talked about Trump
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos
moving to not reimburse certain
defrauded students students who have
been defrauded by the education industry
or world and that's sort of the topic of
today's classic interview we're going
back to October of 2014 when I spoke to
mark Mason who is an expert in corporate
influence over education and we also
talked about standardized testing which
I know is important to others in the
audience as well so let's get to my
interview with mark from 2014 think
about it in the context of what we're
seeing the Trump administration and
Betsy DeVos push now in terms of
education policy I'm joined today by
mark Mason who is a professor of
african-american studies in history at
Fordham University also co-founder of
the badass Teachers Association the
largest education activist group in the
nation the topic today is corporate
influence on education and professor
nation you know I think if you were to
say to many people what is the effect of
corporations on education they might
come up with something like oh is it the
kind of corporatization of college or is
it Doritos and Coca Cola in vending
machines in schools but we're really
talking about something far more
sinister aren't we
absolutely the corporate influence is
shaping what every child will learn from
pre-k through through college and it's
being done largely through influencing
government bodies to impose curricula
that teachers think are burdensome and
inappropriate and sometimes abusive and
the best example of this is the Common
Core Standards which are now being
presented as if they were a bottom-up
initiative by teachers educated and
elected officials organized through the
states when in fact 200mm
million dollars of Bill Gates money was
given to governor's bodies to PTAs to
teachers unions and foundations to try
to push this initiative and when we in
New York State experienced for the first
time test the line to Common Core
teachers parents were and and educators
were just shocked that this had been
imposed on them without any discussion
and also without any ability to modify
them taught a little bit if you can
about the impetus for in other words why
do big corporations want to get involved
in education what is that what is the
ultimate goal well one of them is this
is a huge market it's you know 788
billion dollar market of government
expenditure and education that test
companies technology and software
companies all see as a tremendous market
if you can standardize teaching enough C
you can develop nationwide products for
the market so test companies stand to
make huge profits if there is a national
curriculum that is uniform across the
country so that's one motive is and then
people who are trying to develop a
procedure to have the entire process
digitized hat stand to make a lot of
money from the software but there's
another motivation and that is that a
lot of businesses feel their labor force
is not being properly trained by the
public schools and want to make sure
that there's kind of a uniform level of
of training so that if somebody
graduates from high school you know they
can be employees who can can plug right
into their their companies do you see a
connection or do you see as two
unrelated issues
what you and I have just been talking
about for the last few minutes and the
issue of both the rewriting of textbooks
with a kind of religious impetus or
through religious lens that we're seeing
catalyzed quite a bit in Texas as well
as the fight to teach so-called
controversies around for example
evolution for okay do you see those are
these completely unrelated issues are
completely different initiatives what's
very interesting is that the people
behind Common Core are very much opposed
to those grassroots conservative
initiatives so in if and and if that's
what makes this so complicated initially
the opposition to the sort of top-down
curricular modification was coming a lot
from conservatives and it took a while
for liberals and progressives to realize
wait a minute when big money shapes
education policy that's a subversion of
democracy so there were many issues in
education and one of them is the attempt
to try to undermine you know teaching
that is going on in car in in science
and history to present the more
religious perspective but then there is
an attempt to reshape education policy
from the top-down in a way that really
excludes teachers and parents so we have
a lot on our plate and talk to us a
little bit about once we see or what do
we know I guess is the best way to ask
about what the effects are on students
who go through the education systems
that are so influenced by corporation
what then is the effect when they later
in life enter the workforce for it well
you know this is a very interesting
question I'm a labor historian and I you
know I've done a lot of research in the
1930s when the largest corporation in
the country was General Motors now the
largest corporation in the country is
Walmart which starts off its associates
at 750 an hour even though its CEO
make $16,000 an hour if you are looking
at the kind of jobs we're creating
we're seven out of ten jobs are going to
be entry-level you know moderate to low
wage jobs it seems to me that what we're
doing with a lot of these corporate
policies we're not encouraging critical
thinking we're encouraging rote learning
we're encouraging you know obedience
where in car you know you're not that
you're taking out literature for example
and print putting in sort of you know
very narrow textual analysis you're
removing a lot of studies of history
you're removing hands-on science that is
experimental for things which can be
done on a computer you know it's amazing
as you're saying this and I don't know
if this is my kind of cynical mind going
to a dark place what you're saying in a
way and connecting it to to Walmart as
the biggest employer is reminding me of
when I read the great book brave new
world by Aldous Huxley where there was a
deliberate effort based on the knowledge
that if everybody is very intellectually
curious and fully equipped with critical
thinking and other resources there are
many jobs that they simply would not do
they would not tolerate thus there were
people that were educated or raised in a
particular way to tolerate those jobs
David you are right on target that we I
actually have a former student who is
now a professor at LSU our next book is
going to be on the Walmart ization of
Education what we have is an enforced
standardization from the top down to
reduce education to the lowest common
denominator and take the creativity out
of the classroom and with starting kids
from pre-k we're removing play we're
removing recess all kids do is study for
tests and the tests are expensive so
what gets pushed out when budgets are
strapped or it's music
in school trips you know you're it's
almost like you're making kids adapt to
a brave new world of low paid work where
they have little autonomy and authority
in the last bit of time we have here can
you give our audience some ideas as to
how they can work to counteract lowers
okay the best thing you can do is if you
think testing in your schools are
excessive have your kids refuse to take
the tests there is a growing movement of
test refusal or opting out around the
country and you're talking about the
standardized tests right now not just
tests with a class yes okay I'm also
saying if your kids have recess cancel
to study for tests tell the school
that's unacceptable
tell the schools that there are too many
tests for example in New York State or
third graders take six days of tests 90
minutes a day they take more tests than
you take to get into law school and
medical school I think I go back to you
know the 60s and to me the most horrible
bipartisan initiative in my lifetime
before this was the Vietnam War and
though part of the way we stopped it was
to resist what we thought was an unjust
war now the most destructive bipartisan
initiative is tests based education
policy and I think we have to resist the
tests teachers parents students give you
a number before No Child Left Behind the
average public school gave six tests a
year now they give 17 this is way out of
hand
and the only people can stop it are
parents teachers and older students by
basically saying we won't take the test
unless you cut back and if you're going
to spend money in their schools spend
money and things that make kids love
school which I'm sorry
and also stop scripting teachers and
constantly judging
the basis of test scores and coming in
and observing them on rubrics where you
checkoff little things trust you
teachers to teach all right we've been
speaking with professor mark Mason
professor of african-american studies in
history at Fordham University really a
pleasure to have you on thank you so
much so much I really appreciate the
opportunity to talk about this it's a
very important subject and I think
people don't realize what's going on
until they talk to parents about what's
going on with their kids in school